spediteur frank schaefer seit acht
jahren muss er lange umwege in kauf
nehmen oft im stau er und seine 20
fahrer
der grund die rheinbrücke leverkusen
wegen baufälligkeit ist sie gesperrt für
den schwerlastverkehr schon seit 2012
wir müssen jetzt abwägen weil wir gerade
aus nicht fahren können durch die
ampelschaltung würden die lkw weil sie
direkt abgeleitet
ja und zu meinem leidwesen muss ich
jetzt halt die 30 kilometer umweg in
kauf nehmen und muss halt die mehrkosten
dafür halt aus eigener tasche bezahlen
mehrkosten von jährlich 200.000 euro für
den spediteur und das wohl noch sehr
lange denn die leverkusener brücke ist
mahnmal für missmanagement im
autobahnbau man kann es mit einem wort
zusammenfassen staatsversagen auf der
ganzen linie
viele verkehrsteilnehmer haben das
gefühl von staatsversagen schließlich
steht jeder autofahrer in
ballungsgebieten durchschnittlich 120
stunden pro jahr im stau
es gibt permanent mehr als 500
autobahnbaustellen und jede achte
autobahnbrücke ist marode
ab ersten januar soll sie starten die
autobahn gmbh des bundes sie übernimmt
die zuständigkeit für 13.000 kilometer
fernstraßen von den bundesländern die
autobahnen gmbh untersteht dem eigens
gegründeten fernstraßen bundesamt in
leipzig hamburg februar 2020
bundesverkehrsminister stets verspricht
der großes es ist das drittlängste
autobahnnetz der welt nach china und usa
und wir bemühen uns dass dieses
autobahnnetz auch das beste auf der welt
ist das system wird völlig neu geordnet
und das ziel ist auch klar schneller
planen effizienter bauen und erhalten
sowie direkter finanzieren
doch erstmal wird es richtig teuer
gleich zur gründung zieht die autobahnen
gmbh in luxus büros am leipziger platz
in berlin
die miete pro quadratmeter 123 euro im
monat
kurz darauf zieht die zentrale um und
residiert auf berlins feinster
flaniermeile der friedrichstraße
zwischen juwelier und edelboutiquen die
jahresmiete hier oben im vierten stock
gut 2,3 millionen euro
ende nächsten jahres will show aus
autobahnen gmbh diesen neubau im
modernsten quartier berlins der
europacity beziehen jahresmiete 6,4
millionen euro in berlin fällt es ihnen
auf dass man sich tatsächlich die
teuersten immobilien als mietobjekt
aussucht auch beim neuen standort fällt
auf dass die mietpreise extrem hoch sind
circa 900 euro pro mitarbeiter werden
dort monatlich bezahlt das ist absolut
inakzeptabel und für die autobahn gmbh
alles andere als ein guter start und vor
allen dingen nicht vorzeigbar wer für
ganz deutschland bauen will braucht
offenbar nicht nur moderne büros sondern
auch erstklassige technik und teure
berater haben beraterkosten über 130
millionen euro
da wurde extrem viel geld für teure
berater verpulvert da haben sich
rechtsanwaltskanzleien
unternehmensberater eine goldene nase
verdient am ende war der nutzen für den
bund sehr gering und ich frage mich auch
was sie eigentlich geleistet haben
stattdessen herrsche in der essener
zentrale chaos bei der zusammenführung
von mehr als 1400 softwaresystemen der
bundesländer berichten ehemalige und
aktuelle mitarbeiter die anonym bleiben
wollen die berater einsätze zum teil ja
völlig unnötig völlig überdimensioniert
unfassbar teuer unfassbar uneffektiv die
berater haben dafür gesorgt dass sie
selbst nicht überflüssig werden trotz
fünfmal so hohen beraterkosten wie
geplant wird es zum start der
autobahngesellschaft kein einheitliches
system geben das dauere noch bis ende
2023 teilte das verkehrsministerium mit
bei der einweihung einer teilstrecke der
a 14 magdeburg konfrontieren der
bundesverkehrsminister scheuer mit der
kritik an die autobahn gmbh warum ist
das so teuer dass überlegt ja wir reden
von der größten reform in der geschichte
der autobahn und das hat jeder gewusst
dass das nicht leicht wird natürlich
sind auch die kosten für externe
dienstleister gestiegen wir haben
natürlich auch die eine oder andere
schwierigkeit aber das haben wir jetzt
alles weg gebracht
heuer hat versprochen autobahn bauen
werden schneller billiger und vor allem
effizienter und deswegen sage ich jetzt
liegen dann und sorge nochmal
unfallfreie fahrt gewerkschafter
hermann-josef sie biete roth der auch im
aufsichtsrat der autobahn gmbh sitzt hat
da seine zweifel sich vorstellt welches
system die autobahn gmbh anders anwenden
könnte als wie bislang die
straßenbauverwaltung der länder
schließlich sollen in den neuen autobahn
gmbh dieselben mitarbeiter arbeiten wie
bisher in den ländern
insgesamt sollen 15.000 in die
autobahngesellschaft wechseln
bisher aber sind gerade mal gut 10.000
beschäftigte aus den ländern an bord
obwohl mit besserem tarifvertrag
geworben wird dann natürlich schon groß
ich wechsele aus dem öffentlichen dienst
aus dem arbeitsverhältnis des
öffentlichen dienstes in eine gmbh
längst hat man halt noch mehr aus horst
und aufgaben vergibt personal not schon
zum start nachfrage bei minister wir
haben jetzt schon über 10.000 wie beim
hund am ersten ersten anfangen werden
und wir reden von bis zu 15.000
mitarbeiter kein einfaches werkstück
sondern wirklich was großes das aber uns
dann in der folge dazu bringen soll
dass diese autobahn gmbh das system der
autobahn besser effizienter managen kann
scheuer verspricht autobahnbau aus einer
hand denn bisher plant neben den ländern
auch noch eine weitere gesellschaft mit
450 beschäftigten fernstraßen die
deutsche einheit fernstraßen die dgs ist
nach der wende gegründet worden für den
autobahnbau in den neuen bundesländern
neben den ostdeutschen beteiligten sich
im laufe der jahre immer mehr
westdeutsche länder als gesellschafter
an der dgs noch bis 2036 laufen verträge
für den autobahnbau auftragsvolumen 21
milliarden euro
heuer wollte die dgs mit der autobahn
gmbh fusionieren was sein ministerium
offenbar nicht bedacht hat große
juristische probleme darauf weist der
bundesrechnungshof in der rückschau aus
pläne als unzulässige mischverwaltung
den straßenbau es laut verfassung
ländersache
der rechnungshof warnt sämtliche
aufträge die die länder an die dgs
vergeben haben wären neu auszuschreiben
bei verstößen gegen das vergaberecht
drohen schadensersatzforderungen die
bauindustrie fürchtet bereits eine
pleitewelle
sollte es zu klagen und
neuausschreibungen bereits vergebener
aufträge kommen
aufgrund der vielen juristischen
momentan unklarheiten trauen sich viele
mitarbeiter innen straßenbauverwaltung
natürlich nicht mehr aufträge zu
erteilen
wir haben am ende die befürchtung das
ist so ein stillstand im straßenbau im
bundesfernstraßenbau kommen könnte und
dass wir natürlich ein desaster für uns
alle das ergebnis statt effizienz
planungschaos und doppelstrukturen
was herr scheuer versprochen hat alles
aus einer hand zu liefern wird wohl erst
in vielen jahren möglich sein
es droht ein chaos bei der autobahn gmbh
reformen
die folge das projekt autobahn gmbh wird
viel teurer
allein die verwaltungskosten der
autobahngesellschaft sind mit knapp 1,4
milliarden euro pro jahr veranschlagt
schon im ersten jahres etat 2021 fehlen
satte 400 millionen euro ist gegen die
wand gefahren es wird alles teurer von
tag zu tag ich habe sehr starke zweifel
dass am ende die autobahn reform
überhaupt zu wirksamen synergie effekten
führt und zu wirklich um
kosteneinsparungen bisher sehen wir das
gegenteil zurück nach leverkusen mit
einer schnellen lösung ist hier nicht zu
rechnen weil die brücke so marode ist
wurde 2017 mit einem neubau begonnen
doch seit monaten tut sich nichts mehr
baustopp wegen billig stars aus china
überall bedenkliche schadstellen
spediteur frank schäfer glaubt schon
lange nicht mehr an weniger
verkehrschaos rund ums nadelöhr
leverkusener brücke verspricht deutliche
besserung erwarten sie dass ganz klares
nein also es wäre wünschenswert aber ich
wage es zu bezweifeln
[Musik]